and let's talk some more about
matthew stafford i swear
i've heard more
and seen more quotes from matthew
stafford
in the last week and a half
than i had his entire career
combined
before then but on his way out of
detroit this slow
walk to march 17 when he officially will
be a member of the la rams he had given
an interview to mitch album that was
written up in the detroit free press
here is stafford from the mitch album
show on the guy he's flip-flopping spots
with jared goff here's stafford
has jared goff called you yet have you
talked to me let me want to know where
to go get cones or whatever when you get
there
or what a coney is what a cody
yeah i showed him a text we texted a
little bit just uh you know just told
him that i know going out there i got
big shoes to fill you know it's not not
lost on me that he was in the super bowl
just a few years ago so he's a he's a
really good player in his own right just
want to let him know that uh
you know i i appreciate him as a player
and obviously to reach out to me if if
there was anything he needed when it
comes to detroit um you know just as far
as advice and or you know places to stay
anything
you know i know that uh
he feels that he can reach out to me and
i know i can reach out to him with
anything in l.a too so it's been good
it definitely wasn't mitch album's voice
asking the question i don't know who
else is on that show i hadn't heard
mitch album speak in a long time but i
went through that three seconds of wait
a minute that's not mitch album but
regardless it was the mitch album show
but that was not mitch album asking the
question jared goff from matthew
stafford
and
stafford's always been a humble guy a
quiet guy he's not going to be
boisterous he's not going to acknowledge
the obvious and the obvious is he's a
better quarterback than jared goff jared
goff is more accomplished because he's
had a better team around him he's had a
better coaching staff around him at
least over the past few years
that's why jared goff was in the super
bowl there wasn't some big time throw
that jared goff made
to get the
rams to the super bowl and there were
two big time throws that he missed that
could have helped the rams win the teams
in my view were the thursday nighter
from september of 2018 against the
vikings and then the chiefs
where he out dueled patrick mahomes in
my home's first year as a starter but
but there isn't in my mind this this
sizzle reel that that immediately is
conjured of all these great jared goff
throws and great jared goff moments he
he he just was a guy who
who held it all together and made the
throws he had to make and it wasn't
always pretty and
it was effective more often than not
so
it really is fascinating to think of
what stafford could be
in that offense not the same talent
around him that there was for goff in
2018 but enough and i think enough of a
kick in the butt for sean mcvay
that the offense could be interesting to
say the least with stafford there
yeah if you go back to that nfc
championship game that year mike you
talked about no big time throws you make
if the officials make the pass
interference call against nickel roby
coleman
rams frankly probably don't even get to
the super bowl that year so it wasn't a
lot of jared goff but i tell you what
i'll say this i don't know that there is
a player in the nfl who has more
pressure on him going into 2021 than
matthew stafford because
we are all sitting here saying well he's
only been to one pro bowl he's never won
a postseason game went 0-3 in the
playoffs but it was all because of the
talent in detroit it was all because of
the coaching in detroit you know he's
now going to get coaching he's now going
to have better teammates he's now going
to have a better defense okay but now
you got to go out and prove it mike
it all sounds good on paper and it looks
good and we think the rams have upgraded
here but it's all on matthew stafford to
go out and prove the rams right that he
is better than jared goff that he can
get him over the hump and frankly the
only way you get him over the hump is to
go win a super bowl they've been to a
super bowl with jared goff they have to
go win the super bowl with matthew
stafford for it to be an upgrade
the stat about one pro bowl and look i
hate the pro bowl i was so happy they
didn't play it this year not happy about
the reasons why they didn't play it but
i i don't watch it it's it it makes no
sense anymore it's unnecessary risk for
the players so i'm not going to wag the
finger at the fact that it's two hand
touch in full pads that's what it should
be they shouldn't play it
but
but
they're going to announce a team an
all-star team a pro bowl team no matter
what even if they don't play the game
the idea that matthew stafford only made
it to one in 20 guys every year from the
conference who make it and in the years
where they actually play the game
yeah it's it's more than three because
usually one of those three guys is going
to the super bowl so that's four
and usually one of those guys
easily weasels out of the assignment
with an injury that had never been
disclosed on the injury report or one
that has been which makes it even easier
to weasel out of the assignment so
that's five i mean they start going down
the list
and for it to have only landed on
stafford one time in his career and you
know it's because you got aaron rodgers
around you got russell wilson around you
got other great quarterbacks around
but
i i know one of the one of the various
loose tests for hall of fame worthiness
is
was the quarterback ever the best in the
league
in his career the idea that matthew
stafford was deemed a pro bowler only
one out of 12 seasons
is a pretty damning indictment of his
body of work and i just think he's a guy
who
was just kind of there
he had a 5 000 yard season in 2011 and
he was close to it again i think 2012
the year that
calvin johnson had 1964 receiving yards
and oh johnson was dominant that year an
incredible performance there were four
and 12.
one of the strangest disconnects of
individual performance and team
performance i've ever seen and matthew
stafford's career
was
a disconnect of individual performance
and team performance and i think the
team performance caused not nearly
enough people to notice the individual
performance and the question is you put
him in a different spot i mean this is
kind of a fun trade you put this guy in
a different spot and we find out
was it the lions or was it him
yeah and you talk about the pro bowls
mike like you said everybody makes it
it's normally over a hundred pro bowlers
of course we didn't have all that this
year because they didn't actually play
the game jerry goffs actually made two
pro bowls he's played
made one more pro bowl than matthew
stafford it has and i was amazed when
this trade went down because i thought
matthew stafford was older than what he
is he's 33 i mean he's still got a ton
of his career left in front of him and a
chance to do really great things that he
wasn't able to do detroit in detroit of
course early in his career he had all
those injuries and he couldn't stay on
the field and then he had a stretch when
he was on the field all the time and
then now most recently he's had some
more injuries over the last few years so
the injury history has not been good
with him he needs to stay healthy for
sure but he needs to do all he can to
win too mike to to kind of seal his
legacy here you know number one overall
pick and he's kind of done what most
number one overall picks have done which
is not a ton
just kind of been okay he's kind of had
an okay career if he retired today i
think we'd go okay it was
it was okay it wasn't great it wasn't
good he never won a postseason game
we're certainly not talking about him
for the hall of fame but he's so young
he still has a chance to do all those
things that's the weird thing about his
career he's played for 12 years and has
a chance to still do even more and make
something of this career that he wasn't
able to do in detroit so it's probably
good for him that he got out of detroit
now has a chance to go to a team with
sean mcvay who's excited about this and
will build an offense around him we've
seen it he knows how to do that needs
probably a
few more pieces around him josh reynolds
is among the guys that's a free agent so
he's gonna have to bring in some more
pieces uh maybe cam akers is the todd
gurley that that jared goff had they
certainly need that part of it too
a couple of things i had a moment there
when you pointed out that this year we
didn't have that constant flood of
this guy's going to the pro bowl this
guy's going to the pro bowl this guy's
going to the pro bowl and we don't turn
up our noses at the opportunity to have
content at profootballtalk.com but i can
tell you
i don't miss
the
yeah this guy's not going to the pro
bowl because his team's in the super
bowl so here's the guy who's taking his
place stories i do not miss that and i
have a feeling the audience didn't miss
it at all
speaking of pro bowls though and to put
this in context pete demelitis has
loaded in some of these
derek carr three pro bowls in his career
kirk cousins
this is an i love him day with his two
pro bowls
and others who have won just like
matthew stafford include teddy
bridgewater tyrod taylor mitchell
trubisky jameis winston oh and by the
way andy dalton
has three and you know the the the
right now if matthew stafford retires
he's not getting to the hall of fame
without paying the price of admission
but in this second act with seven years
left
you win a super bowl or two and consider
this shireen i i i pulled these numbers
up and and this is amazing to me
matthew stafford
has more career passing yards 12 years
in
and i know it's the age of passing look
it's been the age of passing since the
late 70s it was the age of passing when
dan fouts and heir corielle started
lighting it up well you know what
matthew stafford's got more passing
yards in his career than dan fouts i i i
i'm wondering whether or not the folks
at pro football reference have this
wrong it doesn't seem right to me to
look at this and see
matthew stafford at number 16
on the all-time passing yardage list at
age 32 turned 33 recently
plenty of football left in the tank
45-109 more than drew bledsoe more than
dan fouts more than joe flacco more than
joe montana more than johnny unitas it's
unbelievable to me and he's not all that
far behind vinnie testaverdi he'll catch
carson palmer this year he'll catch fran
tarkin then i remember targeting retired
with all the records warren moons a
season away
he he is two years from getting into the
top
10 for crying out loud the only active
guys ahead of him and there are several
well three there were four phillip
rivers retired ben rothersberger matt
ryan and aaron rodgers oh wait and tom
brady forgot about him he's going to
take he's going to take over
the all-time record and never look back
from drew brees next year but stafford's
going to finish in the top ten he's got
a chance to finish in the top five
and and that's when
it gets interesting because you've got
eli manning at eight with 57 000 yards
two super bowl wins he'll get in because
he's eli manning and peyton i'm sure has
already started the lobbying to get eli
in but
stafford could end up
top seven top five and
maybe not be a hall of famer
maybe not maybe never win a playoff game
who knows and still finish in the top
five all-time in passing yards it's
unbelievable if that happens
it absolutely i'm unbelievable 282
touchdown passes mike so
he's got a lot of numbers and like you
talked about the 5 000 yard season he
he's had some big seasons and you know i
we just expect him more from him i know
lions fans expected more from him when
they drafted him they were excited and
he came in there and obviously got hurt
right away and
and so he just hasn't lived up to those
expectations and you know it's a new
start for jared goff too frankly and
maybe the the lions can make something
of him i think brad holmes really likes
jared beard golf now the lions have a
lot of free agents especially at the
receiver position that they're gonna
have to figure that out who they're
gonna put with him as far as weapons
goes but we'll see what this guy can do
too mike because he's got a new lease on
life uh in detroit and sometimes these
things are good for quarterbacks they go
and they get a new start they're
refreshed they have the chip on the
shoulder whatever the case may be and uh
and they're better and i certainly think
that could be the case with matthew
stafford it better be the case or the
rams are in trouble and but it could be
also for jared goff not as much sold on
that simply because of what they have
talent wise but it could be
whoever the lion's receivers are though
i'm confident they're going to get open
i'm confident they'll be open
you know why
why if you bite the cor if you bite the
corner's kneecaps he can't run with you
i mean true yes yeah eventually he's
going to wear down if you keep biting
his kneecaps he's not going to be able
to jam you off the line of scrimmage
he's not going to be able to run with
you inside leverage outside leverage
he's not going to be he's not going to
be able to keep up with you after you've
bitten his kneecap several times
throughout the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports